Prof: While we get
settled, in our,
as usual, gradual fashion,
I'm going to turn on one of the
videos involving the last two
CEOs of Polaroid,
and then after that,
we'll get into our normal
routine.
What did you think of those
guys?
Did you like them?
Student:  Yeah.
Prof: Great.
We're going to see part of each
slide--there we go.
We've got two cases this week,
Polaroid and Enron.
They are two cases of dramatic
success and then dramatic
failure.
In understanding capitalism,
think back to everything we've
done so far.
The idea of abrupt change,
of equilibrium always being
dislodged,
equilibrium always disrupted,
and the cardiothoracic systems
case from the end of last week
was exactly such a story,
and Polaroid is very much such
a story.
Enron has a darker cast to it.
It entails the darker side of
the human soul.
And we'll hear about that from
Jim Alexander,
who lived right through the
middle of it,
on Wednesday.
This is a tracing of the sales
volume of Polaroid from 1957
until the firm's demise.
One of the things you can--that
is of interest about this
diagram, is that the sales at
death were not dramatically
below their all time peak.
So sales alone don't tell you
enough to understand what
happened.
This is the stock price,
and this is--what are stock
prices about?
What are the drivers?
I'm not asking for anything
fancy here.
What are the drivers--yes,
back left.
Student:  It's expected
future dividends.
Prof: Okay,
expected future earnings,
along with some special sauce
having to do with future
strategy to maintain share
price.
Student:  Interest rates.
Prof: How would interest
rates play into this?
Student:  Basically,
formulaically,
the expectations--
Prof: Okay--just for
those of us who are from
Illinois, spell it out a little
at a time.
Who's from Illinois here?
I apologize.
Hell, I should have said
Indiana, I'm from there.
Okay, spell it out for us.
Student:  A lower
interest rate will yield a
higher stock price because there
will be less of a tradeoff
between spending today and what
you get tomorrow.
Prof: Well, sort of.
Jim do you want to help with
that?
Jim Alexander:
They really are a
projection of future cash flows
to the shareholders,
it's just that it used to be in
the 1950s,
1960s, and 1970s,
dividends that were the bulk of
those assumptions,
and today it's a rare company
that makes more than 1% or 2%
dividend yield on the stock
price.
So really it's a projection of
earnings which is encapsulated.
When you look at that chart,
what you see is the typical
problem with a lot of growth
stocks and that is people buying
onto a whole new paradigm and
then extrapolates for decades
and you end up with a stock
price that really bears no
resemblance to current earnings.
Prof: And an increase in
interest rates,
how would that view--
Jim Alexander:
That would--
an increase in--all of the
things being equal--
an increase in current interest
rates would lower the stock
price because you would have to
be compensated for the extra
time value of money involved.
Prof: Thanks.
Sales, this is a curve in red
that we saw in the first slide,
with long term debt superposed.
Sales reads on the left axis
and debt reads on the right.
Anything learned from that
slide?
Come on guys,
this is not a curve ball.
Student:  Polaroid
didn't have any debt until
relatively recently in the last
second.
Pretty much starting during the
recession of the recession of
the 1980s
Prof: Was the debt
likely to be important there
toward the end?
Student:  Well,
yeah, because they filed for
bankruptcy.
Prof: They did.
And what was the precise event
that caused them to file?
It's the 10Q filing in the
case, did anybody notice that?
Student:  A takeover
attempt.
Prof: No.
Student:
>
Prof: Seaconch.
Student:  9/11.
Prof: Not really.
It was related to 9/11.
What happened was,
they failed to make a scheduled
payment on the debt and that
triggered an avalanche of
adverse results,
drove the stock price close to
zero,
and how does the firm end up?
What becomes of it?
It gets--sold?
Student:  Sold to the
private equity companies.
Prof: Sold to private
equity, and how much of its
value do you think is--of its
peak value is there at the end
when it's sold to private
equity?
You don't have to give me a
number, just give me a lot/a
little--
Student:  I think 20%.
Prof: I think less,
it sold for $265 million at
that end stage.
Now what was the value
proposition?
I guess that's a hint.
What would have caused
you--here is a Polaroid Pronto,
which hasn't made a picture in
a lifetime,
what would it have cost--I
probably bought over the years
three or four of these cameras.
I was never terrifically happy
with them.
Any of you ever own one?
You're all way too
young--almost all.
Tell us--
Student:  Yeah,
I got one as a birthday present
as a novelty for like,
three months.
Prof: How old were you?
Student:  I was eight.
Prof: So you probably
didn't have an independent
account for buying film?
Do you have any memory of how
the film's price compared--well
you didn't buy the camera.
Student:  No,
I didn't know anything about
the pricing.
I just liked that it came out
instantly.
Prof: Okay,
did anyone own one at an age
older than eight?
Back center--
Student:  I had my
grandmother's old one.
I was 11.
Prof: I can guess what
you paid for the camera.
Student:  I mean it was
a hand me down,
and I took, like,
ten pictures,
and I asked my mom to buy more
and she was like,
"No, we're just going to
get a disposable."
Prof: Okay,
so the sales metaphor in the
case, anybody remember what
analogy do they draw in the
marketing strategy?
Student:  I think it was
razor and blade.
Prof: Razor and blade,
help us understand that.
Student:  Yeah,
basically the current interest
of the company that sells
razors,
they're not making that much
money on the actual price of the
razors,
some could argue that they can
even give that to you.
Their profit really comes from
that people have to buy blades
in order to use the razor.
Prof: Okay, great.
Can we think of any other
analogies in marketing
strategies?
Here in the alligator shirt.
Student:  Printers and
ink cartridges.
Prof: Printers and
cartridges.
You've noticed that the
printers sell for nothing,
and the cartridges cost your
firstborn child.
It's not a bad strategy because
most of us try to minimize the
initial cash outlay when we buy
something and then you get hit
in the back of the head by the
maintenance of it.
And that was the strategy for
Polaroid, and it was in some
periods a very successful
strategy.
What's the value proposition?
We get two dimensions here,
let's put them together,
actually.
The quality dimension,
I think this is 1948;
this is the first Polaroid
camera on the retail market.
It was much too--I was nine at
the time, so I can empathize
with you guys,
but I was nowhere near rich
enough to purchase a Polaroid
Land camera.
It was a very upscale,
fancy idea.
But I did see pictures made
with it, and they were sepia
tone and muddy;
very low contrast.
They were very bad compared
with what could be produced by
conventional photography.
The question was--let's think
about three kinds of consumers,
and this was largely a consumer
product.
It had scientific and business
applications,
and industrial applications,
but from Land's point of view
all the way the real darling was
the amateur photographer.
Let's use indifference curves
in this space,
so we've got speed on the
horizontal dimension and quality
on the vertical dimension,
and a person who says,
"I'm indifferent between
all these outcomes,"
how would we describe that
person's preference?
Student:  A professional.
If he's indifferent to speed;
there's a
>
of quality.
Prof: I'm unable to
locate you.
Where are you?
Wave.
Oh, hi.
It would be a professional or
perfectionist.
The model might be Ansel Adams,
somebody who makes wonderful
pictures and is willing to wait,
and is virtually indifferent to
the time dimension,
so that person is trying to
climb in this direction,
indifference curve over
indifference curve.
This person--Tim what's this
person up too?
They're trying to go out that
way as fast as they can.
Student:  They're trying
to get faster and faster
pictures.
Prof: Yeah,
cheap thrills,
just like our friend back here
when he was eight.
All they want is speed.
How many customers do you think
fit either of these
descriptions?
A few fit the first
description, a few fit the
second description,
but most are more like this.
They have a tradeoff,
which I've simplified with
straight lines,
they probably would actually
bow in toward the origin like
this,
but these people want some
combination of speed and
quality.
The central drive for the
Polaroid Land Camera from 1948
all the way to the end,
was to do as well as possible
in competing for the business of
these people who were trading
off the two dimensions.
The SX-70, which was in some
ways, the high point of
Polaroid's history and in other
ways the low point.
Anybody remember what was wrong
with the SX-70?
Student:  It had battery
problems.
Prof: It had--how--do
you remember from the case how
the battery was related to the
thing?
Student:  Not really.
Prof: I think Jim
Alexander and I are the only
people here who ever experienced
this.
The battery was included in the
film pack, and for the first
couple of years they made it,
about half the batteries were
no good.
If you spent a premium for the
film pack and the battery
wouldn't make the camera run,
you were likely to be an
unhappy customer.
They had a very high complaint
rate about that.
Does anybody remember what they
did to resolve the battery
problem?
Student:  They
manufactured their own
batteries.
Prof: Yeah,
they went into the battery
manufacturing business,
which is as we'll see in a
minute, is an integration move,
where they reduce their
reliance on outside suppliers
but create a whole set of new
problems for themselves,
because it turns out it's not
very easy to manufacture
batteries well.
The Polaroid SX-70 had gained
enormous ground on conventional
photography on the quality
dimension.
It was a lot better than the
old Polaroid,
but it was still--nobody drunk
or sober would argue that the
pictures produced by the
Polaroid SX-70 were as good as
those produced by a conventional
single SLR,
single lens reflex 35mm camera
with competent processing.
They were in a position where
they had a deficit on the
quality side,
which they never actually
overcame.
They did better and better on
picture quality but they never
really got to where they matched
conventional photography.
The--I've drawn this so that
they're on a higher indifference
curve for this particular
consumer than the conventional
photography.
There were several problems
lurking in that.
One of them--how could this
have happened?
Without any improvement in
either the film or the camera on
the conventional side,
the conventional photographic
technology gained ground on the
speed dimension and a gained a
lot of it.
Student:  With the
advent of the one-hour photo.
Prof: Okay,
so the one photo processing
took three days,
or five business days,
and brought it down to an
errand.
You drop the film off,
go have a cup of coffee,
come back, so that conventional
photography with no internal
improvement was closing the
speed gap,
and diminishing total demand
for instant photography.
Now there's an incident about
this stage between Polaroid and
Kodak.
Anybody remember how that goes?
How had--had Kodak played any
part in Polaroid's business?
Any cooperative part in the
early years?
Student:  It
manufactured the camera.
Prof: Yeah it--Kodak was
manufacturing for Polaroid.
As it manufactured it learned
the secret sauce and then went
into the business,
competing and competing
effectively against Polaroid
with a tricked up
reconfiguration of Polaroid's
technology.
Polaroid responded with a
lawsuit.
They won the lawsuit.
They nonetheless got screwed.
How could that be?
They win the--they get a
billion dollars in damages,
or just a little short of a
and yet Polaroid's theft is all
but lethal to them.
Student:  I think it
took them a lot of time and
effort to fight that case,
and when they finally got the
reward,
it wasn't as much as they
expected.
Then there was also this
comment later that they kind of
wished that Kodak had--
that they had merged with Kodak
and that didn't happen,
and that is because Kodak did
not--had too much of an ego.
Prof: Both sides had a
lot of ego.
That's a--you got it.
What was needed was an
immediate intervention.
The case went on almost fifteen
years and while it was going on,
Kodak was eating into the
competitive position occupied by
Polaroid.
There's, of course,
something else going on here
and that's the emergence of
digital.
Digital photography,
with one important asterisk,
trumped everything.
It didn't stand still,
it traced a path,
and it's still on that path of
virtually continuous
improvement.
A $200 digital camera now is as
good as a $10,000 digital camera
a decade ago.
The--hands up if you use a
digital camera?
Yeah, everybody.
On average my guess is that
your digital cameras are about
like that?
They're tiny,
are they hard to work?
Do the batteries fail?
There's only one thing they
don't do very well and what's
that?
Student:  Take pictures
in the dark.
Prof: Well,
they actually do that better
than conventional cameras,
but no camera does that very
well.
What's--my mother hates them,
why would a ninety-five year
old--
Student:  They don't
print.
Prof: They don't print.
Her idea of a photo is
something you hold in your hands
and it's not a real photo unless
she can hold it in her hands,
put it on the coffee table,
show it to her friends from the
coffee table,
and Edwin Land actually agreed
with that.
It was--part of his infatuation
with the original Polaroid idea
was that you make the picture,
wave it for a minute until it
dries,
and hand it to the people who
are in the view.
Now we're going to go back to
the case in this informal way in
just a minute,
but I'm going to talk about
integration here,
because vertical integration is
a huge part of the Polaroid
story,
and it's an important part of
most corporate stories.
Vertical integration is
the--think of the dimension that
starts with raw product ore
coming out of a mine,
sugar cane coming out of a
field, bananas coming out of a
rain forest.
And then there is a progression
toward a manufacturing or
processing plant,
or perhaps a series of
manufacturing steps.
Then the distribution of the
product to wholesalers,
and from wholesalers to
retailers, and from retailers to
the family picnic.
And a full story of vertical
integration looks like this;
everything is in the corporate
box from beginning to end.
The plus of that is obvious.
The trouble you might have with
your suppliers is completely
eliminated, and the ability to
direct the details of every step
is seemingly unlimited.
The downside--there are at
least two obvious downsides.
One is a lot of companies are
good at the front end without
being good at the back end.
If they go from the front end,
from marketing a retail product
all the way back to the first
steps of its production,
they may well screw up because
it's just not what they do well.
That's one difficulty.
Another difficulty is
governance.
The management of a vertically
integrated company is a very
complicated process,
and it tends,
as with the railroads we saw a
week ago,
it tends to bloat the
administrative apparatus,
make it have many dimensions
from top to plant floor,
and presents serious challenges.
Now that's only half the story.
The other half of vertical
integration has to do with
ideas.
There's a--what I just talked
about has to do with physical
stuff, material things.
There is also an intellectual
track or ideational track,
which starts with dreams or
ideas drawn on the back of a
napkin,
and then invokes science and
engineering,
and design, and a marketing
plan.
It is in effect the brains
behind the lower box and with
Polaroid you had a fully
integrated company.
Now they didn't do mines and
fields,
but you had a high degree of
vertical integration in the
ideas process,
and almost as high a degree of
integration in the material
process.
So you end up there.
Now why did this company fail?
Let's start with--I've got warm
calls.
Amed, why do you think the
company failed?
Student:  They failed
because of the capabilities and
beliefs of the 1980s that
influenced their strategies.
They couldn't--they were more
technology driven and not market
driven, and reasons,
and so forth--because of senior
management.
Prof: Okay,
who was this Edwin Land guy?
Student:  A scientist
who--
Prof: He was scientist.
When does he get his start as
an inventor?
Does anybody from remember the
case?
Student:  It didn't say.
Prof: Pardon.
Student:  Harvard.
Prof: Harvard College,
he's an undergraduate,
and he invents Polaroid
filters;
clever lad.
He gets fixated,
I think, on a certain view of
how you do wonderful things and
it focuses on long,
costly, time consuming
research.
Lindsey Jackson,
anything to add to that?
Student:  About Land?
Prof: About Land or
about the causes of failure.
Student:  Well,
I could just go off of
Land's--it was genius what he
was able to do.
He was so technology driven,
and he was able to create such
a successful company,
and at a certain point he
didn't have any competition--
or no real competition--
Prof: No direct
competition.
Student:  And because
this technology was driving and
proved to be successful,
as the company grew older they
got fixated onto something that
technology was going--
result in and drive them,
so they were hesitant change.
Prof: That's terrific.
So we combine an initial
fixation on a very
intellectualized R&D
process,
which is very slow and mildly
contemptuous of marketing,
and we combine that with a
wildly successful market product
which was not designed by
careful analysis of consumer
indifference curves.
It was designed by Edwin Land's
passion for this product.
He correctly guessed,
he lucked out,
he correctly guessed that it
would command an enormous
consumer market,
and sure enough,
it did.
We've got a kind of path
dependent story there.
Ben Chu?
Is there anything left to talk
about on this,
or are we done?
Student:  When Polaroid
was developing its newer
technologies,
it's important to realize that
it's not that they were stuck in
the Stone Age.
They were trying to
develop--they made forays into
digital imagery,
but they still were--they were
still shackled by the idea of
making money with razor blades,
marketing strategy,
and really making money with
printing on film.
Prof: Absolutely.
There's a wonderful quote
toward the end of the piece you
guys read, do you remember it?
Here it is.
They're talking about what a
wonderful and highly marketable
device the digital camera is,
and the--this is a marketing
person talking to a senior
executive,
and the senior executive's
response is,
"Where's the film?
That's where the money is."
Of course there is no film,
and there is no money in film.
All the money is in the
hardware.
That was a hard idea for
Polaroid's top management to
square with the initial model
based on razors and razor
blades.
There's another idea that
appears in--this is one of the
papers cited at the end of the
case.
There's another idea there that
may be important and it's called
bounded rationality.
Hum if bounded rationality is a
familiar concept.
We should stop and talk about
it.
Edwin Land, let's say his IQ
was 290,
since they divide by age I
think he would have had to be
about age three when it was
measured for that to be even
logically possible,
but let's suppose he's the
smartest guy in the world.
He nonetheless thinks in
bounded rationality.
What that means is in order to
get started thinking about
something, you have to
explicitly or implicitly make a
bunch of assumptions.
Those assumptions are typically
arbitrary.
You can't examine every aspect
of every assumption and ever get
anything done intellectually.
It's a true statement.
The task of managing a company
is exceedingly complex.
Edwin Land and Mack Booth and
the other people--
you have this very messy chart
here that I took down from the
case--
none of these senior executives
was ultimately able to think in
a way that was effective,
because the bounding
assumptions prohibited it.
What's so hard about this?
What would make it hard to run
Polaroid or Ford Motor Company?
What--yes--
Student:  Because the
assumptions that they--
Polaroid to begin with was
basically a research driven
company,
and the assumptions that they
were making the benchmark,
was that Polaroid is a research
driven company,
which in effect,
was not correct,
because as the markets were
changing,
it sapped all flexibility to be
nimble and respond to the
competition instead.
Prof: Okay, great.
Is there an analogy in what
happened to them in anything
about the cardiothoracic systems
case?
What was the--I thought Karen
did a--Sharon did a fabulous job
of teaching it.
Why was it that the two-artery
strategy for cardiothoracic
systems had to be abandoned?
Do you remember?
Some of you said it.
Well it is this,
that the companies who were
making the devices for
non-surgical intervention,
the stints, and the little
balloons,
and all that stuff were what
kind of companies?
Huge, well-funded companies,
which were not going to let
somebody come in and take market
share without developing a new
step of competitive device.
One of the very hard things
about running a big company is
that you have to be aware of all
the other players out there who
may be doing something to damage
your market.
They probably aren't even
trying to damage your market;
they are probably not even
thinking much about you,
but instead trying to develop
their own boundedly rational
idea of their company.
In this case Polaroid was badly
bitten,
both by one hour film
processing and by digitals,
and in the case of the one-hour
film processing,
it wasn't even the processors
so much who were in competition
with Polaroid,
but the conventional film
people, such as Kodak.
Part of the story then is
bounded rationality;
part of it has to do with
drawing the wrong lessons from
early success.
Part of it has to do with
something totally irrational,
which was the commitment to a
founder figure.
Is it generally the case that
brilliant engineers run huge
companies which produce the
products based on their ideas?
It's not generally the case.
I mean, we can all name cases,
but in general,
the engineers who create
devices are forced out of top
management and replaced by
people who are general managers.
That's what happened at
Polaroid, but it happened too
late.
It happened much too late.
Now if you were going to save
Polaroid,
let's say in the 1980s,
let's suppose you are Mack
Booth and it's your task to give
this company the best chance of
preserving its value going into
the future,
what would you do?
What they did do was a hell of
a lot of R&D on a long
string of projects which failed.
Some of them were artistic or
engineering successes,
but none of them were economic
successes.
Polar Vision was a disaster,
Helios was actually a really
good product,
but they didn't manage to
recoup their investment.
What would you have done?
If your--are you ready?
Student:  I'm actually
visiting.
Prof: I'm going to cold
call you anyway.
The nice thing is you don't
have anything at risk.
Well you didn't read the case,
so that's unfair.
Are you--
Student:  I am in the
class.
Prof: Okay, good.
What might you have done to
save this company?
Student:  I really do
agree with what Booth said.
He said that he would have
probably merged with Fuji and
kind of use the best aspects of
both,
because Fuji was moving
forward, hopefully digital,
and they were still kind of
doing instant photography.
Because one of the things that
they were still,
I think, fixated upon was
instant photography,
what the founder founded,
so they were--
because that kind of cult,
and if they weren't really
moving on towards other things
and improving on it.
Prof: Okay,
so a merger might well have
been the best play.
Now why would it--what would
make it hard to do?
Student:  I think it's
the culture of the company that
they would--
it's the whole ego trip thing,
they don't really--
kind of like they had to cheat
and the vertical integration was
part of the reason they were so
proud of it.
Prof: Oka,y so part of
it is culture.
I think that debt of theirs
would have weakened their
bargaining position.
Yes.
Student:  Rather than
mergin a company,
I think that Polaroid could
have done something along the
lines of what IBM is doing now,
become a completely research
based company,
cut out their marketing,
cut out their consumer
processes,
and just research for Fuji,
research for,
conduct new research designs
for other companies who are in
the consumer field.
So cut down on your vertical
integration.
Prof: Okay,
that might actually--that makes
a certain kind of sense.
Talk a little more and defend
the idea.
Student:  Because at the
end of the day,
the whole company culture was
driven towards cutting edge
research.
A lot of their successful
products were because they were
able to invent and create
products that were successful on
lines of,
not success of marketing,
not successful marketing
strategies,
but they were able to create
products which were ahead of the
curve in terms of technology.
Since the whole market,
the industry was moving towards
the addition of platform,
perhaps they could become
leaders of developing these
technologies with the improved
digital products in the future.
Prof: Okay,
that's a very interesting
suggestion.
Yes.
Student:  I still think
that the merger wouldn't go well
because of the vertical
integration that Polaroid had in
place.
They had huge facilities and
machines designed for peak times
and sales.
And these fixed costs would
have been a big problem for
Kodak, so I think they wouldn't
merge with them.
Prof: That might well be.
I mean they might have
liquidated those through private
equity and kept intact the rest.
Student:  I think they
were specialized on the films of
Polaroid.
Prof: Yeah, okay.
Let's turn to Enron now.
Enron is another innovation
company.
Jim, can you come up for just a
second?
I didn't warn him about this.
Jim, as I said to those of you
who were here at the beginning
of shopping period,
Jim was Chief Financial Officer
of Enron Global Power &
Pipeline,
and saw the process from the
beginning.
He came from a long career in
investment banking before that.
Culture of innovation at Enron,
was it important from day one
when you were arrived there as a
consultant?
Jim Alexander:
Yes, it was a culture of
innovation that was impressed
upon the organization by Ken
Lay,
because he was trying to avoid
the mindset that was typical of
natural gas pipelines at the
time,
which was very much a monopoly
rate based rate of return,
it doesn't matter if you make
any money kind of a mindset,
and he went way overboard in
reversing that.
Prof: Okay,
was Ken Lay a famous manager,
and was Enron receiving prizes,
for example,
from The Harvard
Business School as the best
run company in the country?
Jim Alexander:
Yes, I've always thought
that--
Prof: Jim is a graduate
of Yale College and HBS,
so we whipsaw him here a
little.
Jim Alexander:
One of those things I've
always thought people ought to
do though is in terms of looking
at industries in decline is to
look at plaudit's from HBS and
the percent of graduates from
HBS going to a given industry.
Prof: Okay,
so the case for Wednesday is
"Innovation
corrupted,"
it's an HBS case,
and it was in that packet of
three which you got a week ago.
Please read it with care.
Jim and I will do this
interrogatively;
we'll sit together and talk it
through, and turn to you
intermittently for help in
solving Enron's dilemmas.
I'd like to meet briefly with
the graduate students who are in
this course at the--at now.